[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de France 24 Mi
nombre es Ángela Gómez nuestro tema de
análisis en esta ocasión es la
relevancia de los acuerdos alcanzados
entre México y Estados Unidos que entre
otras cosas anunciaron polémicas medidas
para disuadir la migración ilegal los
anuncios se concretaron en una en una
reunión de alto nivel en Washington la
semana pasada vamos a conversar sobre
este tema y para ello hemos invitado a
Thomas Kennedy quien es Vocero de la
coaliciones de inmigrantes de la Florida
y también a Mauricio Palma Gutiérrez en
quienes internacionalista con maestría
en historia globales de la London School
of economics y en estudios globales de
la Universidad de Lips de quien ha
estudiado ampliamente la migración
venezolana a nuestros televidentes se
les recuerdo que también son parte del
debate dejen sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter Facebook e Instagram
no se encuentran como arroba el debate
de guión bajo
f-24@angelacof24 mi cuenta personal y la
etiqueta es numeral el debate f24 no
olviden además que todos los contenidos
de nuestro programa están disponibles en
Apple podcast en Spotify en deezer y
también en TuneIn comenzamos vamos
primero con un poco de contexto sobre
las devoluciones de venezolanos y sus
condiciones que son lejanas a los
Derechos Humanos
estos migrantes transitaron miles de
kilómetros a través de fronteras trochas
y selvas cuando creían Ver el final La
pesadilla comenzó de nuevo no se dirigen
a nosotros de retiren sus pertenencias y
yayos en ningún momento nos dijeron que
ustedes van a ser deportados nada
solamente nos sacaron y Nos llevaron
allá el llanto dio paso a la
incertidumbre después de pisar suelo
estadounidense estos venezolanos fueron
deportados a Tijuana México dando inicio
al programa del gobierno estadounidense
pactado con las autoridades mexicanas
para frenar el creciente flujo
migratorio que llega por tierra
por favor que vean este caso no sabemos
qué hacer estamos en el Limbo Estados
Unidos no nos da una solución y México
tampoco la ruta que puede durar meses
inicia en Venezuela la mayoría cruzan el
peligroso tapón del Darién fronteras
selvática entre Colombia y Panamá si lo
logran al periplo continúa por todo
Centroamérica hasta el norte de México
donde las mafias les ayudan a cruzar a
Estados Unidos Washington señaló que
ofrecerá estatus legal a 24.000
venezolanos siempre y cuando éstos
lleguen por vía aérea y cuenten con un
patrocinante marginando así a los
migrantes más vulnerables porque estamos
viviendo una locura aquí todo no sabemos
qué hacer Tenemos es hambre hermano en
México aquí en la frontera ahí sabe Ahí
está ahorita al muro No hayamos que
hacer estamos jodidos no sabemos nos
sacaron sin decir mira está deportado si
no fueran deportados que me manden para
Venezuela un avión yo tuviera tranquilo
en Venezuela ya que me mande para
Venezuela pero Nos soltaron aquí en la
frontera qué hacemos ante esta situación
muchos están llamando a familiares y
amigos que en la ruta hacia el norte
Para ocupar en su tránsito y es que en
lo que va de año las autoridades
fronterizas contabilizaron más de
155.000 migrantes venezolanos el triple
que el año anterior la más reciente
reunión de alto nivel entre México y
Estados Unidos tuvo lugar en Washington
y allí los temas fueron la seguridad el
tráfico de armas y por supuesto la
migración como eje central con el foco
puesto en los venezolanos para mi
primera pregunta Quisiera darle la
bienvenida a Thomas Kennedy Vocero de la
coaliciones de inmigrantes de la Florida
y Tomás entre octubre del 2021 y agosto
del 2022 más de 150.000 migrantes
venezolanos fueron detenidos en la
frontera Sur con Estados Unidos sin
embargo el anuncio de la Casa Blanca
pretende cobijar apenas a 24.000
venezolanos ese coherente de una cifra
con la otra será suficiente
disculpa si no absolutamente no va a ser
suficiente y estamos viendo una crisis
humanitaria una crisis política en
Venezuela que está empujando lo que se
puede escribir como un Éxodo hace años y
que está empeorando
con paso del tiempo una de las preguntas
que tenemos nosotros y otros grupos Pro
inmigrantes que abogan por el derecho
del inmigrante aquí en los Estados
Unidos es como llegaron a esa cifra de
24.000 y otra pregunta es cómo van a ser
los venezolanos
para llegar de forma aérea los Estados
Unidos cuando no existen en muchas
posibilidades de venir de ruta aérea
desde Venezuela a los Estados Unidos y
se les niega paso por países como México
entonces vemos como un
una una
un paso negado a estas personas que
están obviamente
en una situación extrema desesperada y y
también se entiende que en los Estados
Unidos no no está el sistema
migratorio para darle los servicios
necesarios a estas personas nosotros lo
vemos en Miami por ejemplo donde yo
recibo todo el tiempo que vienen
familias de Venezuela y terminan en la
calle no hay servicios no hay apoyo
Entonces el sistema está colapsado en
los Estados Unidos y los fondos
van mucho al sistema de detención a las
cárceles privadas para los inmigrantes
no hay no no no nadie lo suficientes
recursos en el en lo humanitario no
Entonces es una falla total del sistema
migratorio que no sólo de esta
administración ha sido por décadas y se
ha exacerbado y vemos que en el eso los
dos partidos no pueden llegar a un
acuerdo para reformar el sistema algo
que tenga sentido común evidentemente es
un problema que viene desde hace décadas
y que se ha venido acumulando y se ve en
la frontera sur de Estados Unidos más
aún después de que comenzó la pandemia
de Kobe 19 y ahora Quisiera pasar a
Mauricio para la misma pregunta Mauricio
Palma internacionalista y que además ha
investigado los flujos migratorios de
los venezolanos a través de los Andes
Usted cree Mauricio que esta medida de
24.000 visas para que lleguen por aire
los ciudadanos venezolanos legalmente
Estados Unidos son suficientes cuando
estamos hablando de cientos de miles que
llegan por tierra no sin duda no es
suficiente aquí lo que está intentando
hacer el gobierno de Joe biden es tratar
de recubrir con un Halo de generosidad
de una política que es sin duda
discriminatoria y que además Está
tratando de continuar con lo que otros
gobiernos de los Estados Unidos han
venido elaborando en las últimas dos
décadas 3 que es una política
externalizar sus fronteras externalizar
fronteras quiere decir tratar de llevar
más allá de lo puramente territorial el
control migratorio este acuerdo de
entender a México como un segundo o
tercer país seguro algo que ya estaba
ahí embebido en Mexicali y se ha ido
entonces ampliando cada vez más hacia el
sur y con esto lo que se busca es
transferir la responsabilidades del
control migratorio a otros países de la
región con el fin entonces de seguir
apartando y eligiendo aquellos que son
vistos como migrantes que sí merecen
entrar hacia los Estados Unidos este en
el segmento anterior se preguntaban Cuál
era el porque ese número y bueno ese
número lo que quiere mandar es un
mensaje que en apariencia de una
voluntad de resolver un problema Por lo
menos de darle una cierta un cierto
valor humanitarismo al asunto Pero al
final ese es un número que simplemente
deja un espacio para unas personas que
dentro de este proceso de movilidad
humana que están complejo y donde hay
tantas digamos
experiencias
diversas de mucha vulnerabilidad pues
muy pocas personas realmente pueden
acceder a lo que está ofreciendo en este
momento el gobierno de los Estados
Unidos entonces detrás de esto hay una
construcción política y geopolítica
también que hay que llevarla siempre muy
digamos al detalle porque el está
en los detalles claro es que 24.000 le
suena grande cuando uno lo revisa pero
si uno va a revisar las condiciones de
los migrantes y el problema real que
está sucediendo en la frontera Sur Pues
nos surgen más preguntas Mauricio porque
hablemos un poco de estas condiciones de
elegibilidad que no son las mismas
porque es que no todos estas no todas
estas personas que han venido cruzando
América hacia el norte tienen las
características de las personas que está
pidiendo Estados Unidos que puedan
aplicar de manera legal para empezar
financiación la capacidad de comprarse
un tiquete aéreo y entrar por aire
Porque además Pues esa es otra de las
condiciones entonces Cuáles cuáles son
los los venezolanos que sí son elegibles
para entrar al país y cómo esto se
convierte es más bien en una forma de
discriminación contra los que realmente
no tienen nada y atraviesan en
condiciones absolutamente infrahumanas
el territorio americano
Busca calificar y dividir a las personas
que entran hacia los Estados Unidos en
este caso venezolanos en virtud de unas
condiciones que son arbitrarias digamos
por los niveles de capital que tengan de
antes las conexiones que tengan de
dentro de una discusión que nos lleva a
hablar entonces de las desigualdades
estructurales en las que toda la
sociedad es no solo en latinoamericanos
sino la estadounidense también Pues
están en bebidas
no no no no necesitaría ser más que una
un análisis a ojo muy rápido para darse
para que las condiciones se relacionan
con capacidad económica Pero además de
su capacidad acceder a papeles
documentos y además de eso tener
contactos previos en los Estados Unidos
y todo esto se engloba entonces en una
política donde la tenencia de medios es
sustancial y cuando usted piensa
entonces en las personas que vemos en
las imágenes y que además de eso o han
estado durante varios años ya por todas
las Américas buscando diferentes medios
hacer una buena vida pues estas
condiciones económicas no están entonces
revestir de humanitarismo esta política
Pues creo que es cínico ante no sé la
inexistencia de Otra palabra para
describirlo bueno es que estamos viendo
las imágenes aquí mientras estamos en el
programa que han recogido las agencias
internacionales sobre lo difícil que es
este paso y quisiera volver ahora a
Tomás Kennedy tomas para preguntarle
Pues cuál es su opinión sobre el tema
porque finalmente
con la llegada de Joe biden a la casa
blanca pues había una amplia esperanza
de que hubiera ese humanitarismo que
mencionaba Mauricio y que cambiara la
política que se llevó durante el
gobierno de Donald Trump y además
cobijada por la pandemia y prueba de
ellos que empezaron a llegar muchas
muchas más personas a la frontera sin
embargo eso no pasó los que siguen
necesitando entrar urgentemente que
dejaron todo en sus países y que se
sometieron a cualquier cantidad de
violaciones de Derechos Humanos para la
frontera Sur Siguen sin tener un acceso
ni siquiera ahora van a tener la
posibilidad de presentar una solicitud
para ser refugiados
Sí y quiero decir que tengo mucho de
acuerdo con Mauricio me parece que todo
lo que dijo tiene razón
la administración de tubo tiene
políticas migratorias más amistosas que
la administración de Trump y no se puede
olvidar que le ha dado TPS estatus
temporario protectivo a varios países y
le ha redessignado
ese estatus a otros por ejemplo
Venezuela se le resignó en el en el 20
se le designó en el 2021 pero una de las
cosas que
a nosotros no has disgustado más de la
administración Es que no ha retirado el
título lo que se llama el título 42 que
es una política migratoria en la
frontera ni le niega el derecho
internacional y nacional a las personas
que buscan refugio y asilo en este país
es a base de causas de salud pública
relacionadas con la pandemia pero fue
una una política
diseñada por Steven Miller una de las
personas más antimigrantes la
administración de Trump que estaba que
viola el derecho estadounidense e
internacional para las personas que
busquen asilo en este país Entonces
si tenemos muchas muchas críticas y
tengo que reiterar que el número de
24.000 Es realmente muy muy pequeño
Especialmente cuando uno
lo compara con lo con la crisis política
y humanitaria que se está experimentando
en Venezuela hay otra cosa
disculpe que lo interrumpa Pero además
es que las personas que están por tierra
no tienen redes de apoyo que les
permitan ser elegibles para ese nuevo
procedimiento que que lanzó Estados
Unidos en un acuerdo con México y además
quería quería pedirle que habláramos un
poco de las organizaciones
internacionales acnur oim unicef
emitieron comunicados diciendo con
satisfacción esta decisión este acuerdo
negociado por Estados Unidos con México
pero es que estas organizaciones en el
fondo son las que tienen que velar por
el bienestar de las personas y son las
que tienen que ir más allá de las
fronteras para ver que estos migrantes
tengan algún tipo de protección eso no
está pasando
no no está pasando y hay lo que te decía
cuando en el primer segmento en el que
hablé hay mucha desorganización
aquí en los Estados Unidos en términos
de recursos servicios en Cómo recibir a
estos inmigrantes estos refugiados
cuando llegan aquí por ejemplo los
mandan para que hagan su check-in su
chequeo con las agencias migratorias con
Ice y por ejemplo aquí en la Florida los
mandan al centro de la ciudad de Miramar
y la gente puede tener que viajar dos
tres horas para hacer su chequeo
rutinario los mandan lugares donde tal
vez no tienen familiares o alguna tipo
de recursos no tienen dinero no tienen
albergues hemos visto familias que han
llegado aquí en la Florida
padres madres hijos que están en la
calle están en la calle y los tiran aquí
y no tienen ningún tipo de apoyo y y
Mauricio hablaba de como esto es un
problema dijo la palabra geopolítica
pero también es un problema afectado por
la política interna de los Estados
Unidos y la política electoral porque
hemos visto que varios gobernadores y
especialmente el partido republicano
para ser honesto han usado este
este tema de la migración la frontera
como una una lanza de ataque durante las
elecciones que vienen ahora en noviembre
y hemos visto por ejemplo aquí el
gobernador en la Florida
rondesantes que ha mandado a inmigrantes
venezolanos a Massachusetts a la isla de
marta's en un circo político porque ahí
son demócratas diciendo que O si quieren
inmigrantes y van a tener políticas
inmigrantes tomen a estos inmigrantes y
los mandan sin avisar sin ningún tipo de
apoyo dándoles información incorrecta
para que procesan sus casos le dieron
información tan incorrecta
estos inmigrantes van a calificar para
visas u y Probablemente van a poder
conseguir su estatus en este país
gracias a Dios en Nueva York por ejemplo
estamos viendo una una crisis muy grande
en términos del alcalde r Adams en cómo
le dan servicios a los inmigrantes que
están llegando ahí y todo es exacerbado
como línea de ataque política por la
oposición Y eso causa este tipo de
políticas anti inmigrantes donde la
administración de biden tiene que
proyectar fuerza y que tiene la frontera
bajo control no Claro pero Mauricio
usted no cree que los demócratas también
están haciendo uso de sus estrategias
políticas faltando un mes o poco menos
para las elecciones de medio término
porque finalmente yo vayan hace este
anuncio de este acuerdo migratorio que
incluye visas temporales para
venezolanos Pero además para otros
ciudadanos de Centroamérica que que por
la vía de la migración
pero al mismo tiempo mantiene el título
42 entonces pues esto pasa por populismo
Pues cuando espera
el ala demócrata tener el poder para que
yo bailen mantenga su gobernabilidad
entre comillas
sino
decir sobre la la filigrana interna creo
que el gobierno y bueno el partido
demócrata Está tratando de hacer un acto
de balanceo con miras a lo que viene con
el elección y creo que en ese acto
balanceo estaba decidido a sacrificar y
a estas personas
incluso a otros a otras personas otras
nacionalidades Porque cuando uno mira el
por ejemplo las visas que también se
anuncian para los países
centroamericanos en este comunicado de
homeland Security y también siguen
hablando de unas visas que solamente se
pueden obtener en el caso de personas
que tienen unas características
muy especiales y No necesariamente
aquellas que necesitan protección
internacional de países como El Salvador
y Honduras entonces ahí Creo que hay un
hay un mensaje un poco haciendo digamos
eco de lo que ha venido pasando en los
traslados estos
denigrantes con engaños no que hubo
desde la frontera sur de los Estados
Unidos y también es de Florida y hacia
ciudades como Bueno ella ya lo
mencionaba
famoso el martes vanger etcétera y y
también Está tratando de hacer mesa de
político como Bueno cuando cuando
queremos podemos tomar acciones de
control con este revestimiento
humanitario es decir es un acto balanceo
que se supone que se enmarca dentro de
la política demócrata del partido
demócrata Pero al final Es la
continuación de de un control muy
abrupto sobre la movilidad de las
personas con esas afectaciones pues
terribles en términos de Derechos
Humanos donde hay pues una negación
absoluta de
que las personas puedan acceder a su
derecho de pedir asilo en este caso
claro es que es difícilmente con las
condiciones que ustedes nos describen
podríamos catalogar esto de acciones
humanitarias o con características de
humanitarismo ya para ir cerrando esta
parte sobre Venezuela quisiera
preguntarles a los dos sobre esta
decisión que se da en el contexto de las
relaciones entre Estados Unidos y
Venezuela que parecen estar dando un
giro y pasar a otro capítulo entonces
quisiera pedirles que me hagan ustedes
la relación entre este anuncio que hace
Estados Unidos en una reunión de alto
nivel con México pero que se concentra
en Venezuela y que previamente tiene
como antesala la liberación de los dos
sobrinos de Nicolás maduro que estaban
condenados por narcotráfico en Estados
Unidos y además de este aligeramiento o
de algunas de las sanciones contra
Venezuela en lo que respecta al petróleo
es decir no es coincidencia que en los
últimos tres o cuatro meses Venezuela
haya estado en el centro de la agenda de
Estados Unidos y joeyden permitido ver
muy muy claramente comienzo Thomas con
usted
Sí bueno cuando Trump era presidente
asesores de seguridad Nacional del le
dijeron que no use la opción nuclear en
términos de las sanciones más agravadas
que dieron al contra el gobierno
venezolano porque si no podían derrocar
a maduro y el gobierno de maduro iba a
demostrar debilidad en parte del de los
esfuerzos americanos que es realmente lo
que terminó pasando y ahora lo que
estamos viendo Es que con la En mi
opinión que con la crisis en en Europa
la guerra entre Rusia y la invasión de
Rusia Ucrania hay una crisis energética
y el el mercado de petróleo se ha
ajustado porque el petróleo ruso está
siendo sancionado entonces creo que el
gobierno está estadounidense Está
tratando de Buscar petróleo en el
mercados que antes
no eran
políticamente
accesibles
aceptables claro para para los
americanos no Y para demostrarle también
a la opec a savia Arabia que hay otros
mercados que los Estados Unidos antes
tal vez no como dijiste no le resultaba
aceptable Pero ahora sí entonces creo
que tiene que ver todo con el petróleo y
el sector energético la relación más
pues se podría decir amistosa entre
Venezuela y Estados Unidos ahora Muy
bien Mauricio ahora quisiera su opinión
y le agrego esta esta gran frase que
sale en el comunicado emitido por México
y también por el homeland Security Y es
que este nuevo pacto que pretende dar
más protección a una cierta cantidad de
migrantes venezolanos está basado en el
programa que se llama Unidos por Ucrania
que tiene un origen completamente
diferente de un contexto completamente
diferente entonces como uno puede
equilibrar dos fenómenos
que vienen que vienen que vienen de
conflictos tan distintos al mismo tiempo
que pues Estados Unidos digamos que hace
pinitos para para suavizar las
relaciones con Venezuela
yo creo que en este momento es un juego
de demostrar y esconder que se juega
varias bandas entre Venezuela y Estados
Unidos contra Estados Unidos y Venezuela
ahí nos interlocutores México es uno de
ellos y para que México sirva como
interlocutor no es solamente que que
preste su territorio o sus buenos
oficios para que funcionarios de ambos
gobiernos se comiencen a charlar sino
para que también a través del mismo
gobierno mexicano se expresen intereses
y se expresen el posibles líneas de
acción estamos mencionado que los
cambios en el contexto global
geopolítico económico pues han hecho
entonces que que se comiese especular
sobre la posibilidad de un acercamiento
e incluso pues la que se quitan algunas
de las sanciones en este caso pero
mientras que eso se hace en lo que yo yo
iría en ese esconder no también se
muestra que por el otro lado se sigue
por lo menos presentando ante el mundo
que Estados Unidos sigue considerando la
situación venezolana un tema humanitario
mayor y ahí es un poco tratando de
resolver la pregunta de Cuál es la
lógica al menos la que yo percibo detrás
de porque el gobierno Entonces busca
asociar esto con el tema de Unidos por
Ucrania
y cuando uno lo lee ya como un todo no
como esto de lo que hay debajo de la
política migratoria y lo que están
dispuestos a sacrificar en términos de
vida en este caso por el mismo tiempo
como ante el contexto internacional
sigue siendo mostrado como si los
Estados Unidos pensaran en que toda la
situación sigue siendo un problema
humanitario mayor más los factores
geopolíticos pues al final no se da
cuenta que que los migrantes y las
personas están ahí puestas como como
como un juego como como un objeto dentro
del juego político dentro de algo que ya
no vemos una solución a ciencia cierta Y
eso es lo más dramático porque al final
entonces dentro de esa negociación
política es quitar y poner ese Mostrar y
esconder a varias bandas pues son los
migrantes son las personas no solamente
venezolanas sino los migrantes que
genera la gente que se mueve Tratando de
buscar pues una buena vida como
cualquier persona tiene derecho a
hacerlo las que finalmente se ven más
afectadas bien y ahora vamos a dejar
descansar por un momento el tema de
Venezuela porque también hubo otros
puntos migratorios que se hablaron en
este acuerdo que realizaron México y
Estados Unidos tomas uno de los temas en
los que también fue muy enfática la
parte estadounidense fue el combate de
las pandillas en Haití Este es un tema
por sí mismo y de hecho lo trataremos
más adelante en el debate pero al fin y
al cabo lograr a Washington de
incentivar El viaje de haitianos que
cruzan a través de México esto en el
contexto de un gobierno muy inestable en
Haití que le pide a la comunidad
internacional que haga una intervención
para ese combate contra las pandillas
Sí el gobierno de ti es más allá que
inestable es un país fallido
Lamentablemente donde no hay
electricidad
no hay agua potable en muchos sectores
de la capital Puerto Princess
la violencia las pandillas han tomado
control el ejército y la policía no
tiene ningún tipo de control sobre la
capital Más allá del país entonces La
respuesta es no no van a Desactivar o
sea esa gente Realmente está escapando
una situación desesperada pero
desesperada pero desesperada mucho más
desesperada que la situación en
Venezuela que también es una situación
extremadamente desesperada y
en cierto modo es entendible que tenga
que haber una intervención en el país
porque las pandillas están fuera de
control pero en mi opinión no va a
resultar En nada bueno porque la
historia de Haití esta repleta de
intervenciones extranjeras muchas veces
lideradas por los Estados Unidos los los
Marines ya ocuparon la isla y nunca se
resolvió nada al respecto Entonces es
una situación muy muy triste
que realmente yo no te podría decir cuál
es la solución
Mauricio su opinión en el caso el tema
de los números sigue siendo algo que es
una duda bien gigantesca Es sobre todo
cuando no sólo de inestabilidad política
después de pues de lo que sucedió hace
un año con el asesinato de
líder haitiano y hoy con la criminalidad
sino con otros temas que han venido
surgiendo en las últimas semanas Como
por ejemplo un posible brote de cólera
lo que puede ser una epidemia mayor y
además de eso el cierre absoluto que ha
propuesto el gobierno dominicano para el
paso de personas desde aquí entonces
en las últimas décadas quizá desde los
años 80 ha habido un un esquema y un
sistema de emigración y en movilidad
entre Haití otras islas del Caribe pero
también tranquilos Estados Unidos que se
digamos se puede ver como que se ha
mantenido en el tiempo dentro de
diferentes mecanismos de muchísima
precariedad
y creo que con este anuncio que ese
escaso que no es digamos suficiente para
lo que se viene es muy posible que
estemos a las puertas de una nueva
situación donde va a haber mucha gente
tratando de irse al mar por su propia
cuenta para tratar de tomar camino desde
la desde Haití hacia otros lugares en el
Caribe buscando también los Estados
Unidos y esta podría ser entonces una
situación humanitaria Pues de unas
dimensiones que desafortunadamente ya
conocemos pero que hoy acentuadas con
las demás situaciones migratorias como
la de las personas venezolanas y las de
otros personas que también están
altísima vulnerabilidad pues puede
resultar dramático sobre todo dentro del
clima político y de tanta restricción
Pues que se ha venido formando y se ha
venido generalizando en Estados Unidos y
en el Continente en general
no olvidemos precisamente Mauricio y
Thomas que
los haitianos así como otros ciudadanos
Centroamericanos así lo dice el
comunicado serían beneficiarios de otras
20.000 visas temporales para actividades
no agrícolas hay que ver pues qué es lo
que va a pasar realmente con estos
visados porque tampoco responden a la
realidad de los migrantes en este
momento hay miles de migrantes que están
varados en necoclí en Colombia y en
diferentes puntos del continente que ya
no saben qué hacer los venezolanos
principalmente no saben si continuar su
camino y muchos que han decidido
quedarse en estos países de paso donde
su situación Pues por supuesto tampoco
va a mejorar y siguen en medio de la
precariedad y sometidos a violaciones y
abejaciones de los Derechos Humanos
entre tanto algo que sí se deja ver muy
claramente es que Estados Unidos está
mostrando una política muy activa frente
a América Latina está esta reunión de
alto nivel con México pero también está
la reciente gira por ejemplo de Anthony
blinken por Colombia Chile y Perú y pues
estas movidas que hemos hecho
seguimiento en los últimos meses frente
a Venezuela
qué podemos decir sobre este este cambio
de estrategia o esta ampliación de la
actitud de Joe biden hacia América
Latina tomas comienzo con usted
sí Bueno creo que tiene que mucho que
ver con
lecciones que el departamento de estado
aprendió desde la administración de Bush
y la administración de Obama que en
donde no le prestaron mucha atención a
la política latinoamericana y vieron
varios gobiernos de izquierda y centro
izquierda electos en la región y estamos
viendo de nuevo eso pasar en Colombia
en Argentina en chile y eso obviamente
manda la atención del departamento de
estado y y y y la administración y
también
estamos viendo que
hay países como Haití y como Venezuela
donde está donde ha habido mucha
corrupción y una gran movida de personas
hacia hacia
de la fronteras estadounidense o por las
frontera sur o por el mar y por gente
obviamente gente desesperada que está
viniendo a este país buscando una vida
mejor y seguridad
entonces creo que esos son los factores
que están demandando la atención de la
administración y desafortunadamente
Como dijo Mauricio creo que lo están
haciendo de forma incorrecta porque
24.000 personas de Venezuela y 20.000
personas de Haití realmente Es un chiste
considerando la cantidad de gente y que
va que
va a ser desplazada y está haciendo si
está desplazándose y la necesidad
humanitaria que hay presentemente y la
va a ver en el futuro bien entonces ya
nos estamos acercando Lamentablemente al
final es de este programa y por eso
quisiera pedirles a los dos sus
conclusiones y aquí mi pregunta final
comienzo Mauricio muy rápidamente este
plan fue anunciado como el intento más
reciente para frenar el número récord de
cruces ilegales en la frontera entre
México y entre Estados Unidos después de
todo lo que estamos hablando es real esa
expectativa de reducir la migración
ilegal a través de las fronteras
terrestres
no y creo que lo que hay que siempre
recordar es que el movimiento de las
personas excede a los Estados
primero fue el movimiento y luego venir
los estados primero fue el derecho a y
desplazarse y luego vinieron las
fronteras y eso es algo que la política
contemporánea basada en esta idea de
soberanía que discrimina y que mal
entiende y que estaba enfocada en
producir a través de unas lógicas que se
salen de la comprensión humana a veces
pues finalmente olvidan y creo que es
por ahí donde uno podría repensarse Cuál
es el futuro y cuáles son los caminos a
seguir de aquí en adelante
y tomas su conclusión por favor
la misma que Mauricio y las personas
siempre van a hacer cosas
extraordinarias
para buscar una vida mejor no solo para
ellos mismos pero especialmente para
para sus hijos no para su familias
Entonces sí la gente va a seguir
migrando y ningún tipo de política anti
inmigrante o política de no
enforzamiento migratorio va a parar eso
pues viene el agradecimiento es para
nuestros invitados por habernos
entregado un poco más de contexto y pues
de realidad sobre esos anuncios de
Estados Unidos tomas Kennedy Vocero de
la coaliciones de inmigrantes de Florida
y Mauricio Palma Gutiérrez
internacionallista Eso es todo por hoy y
En nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos su sintonía y la producción
del programa que estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón Así mismo la producción de
nuestros invitados a cargo de Tania
Herrera y de Samuel Salgado muchas
gracias a ustedes
[Música]